jim jackson nba on tnt analyst and uh he
was on the call
nba tv yesterday jim i've watched you a
lot of times in your career
college and pro you had one of your best
performances of your life yesterday
i appreciate the honesty and doing that
on live tv um
when you saw this was uh unfolding right
there in front of you when did you get
an
inkling that something was up that the
bucks were probably not going to play
this game
first of all dan thank you uh you know
for having me on your show this morning
thanks for the thanks for the kind words
uh early in the day we heard some
rumblings about maybe
the toronto raptors were thinking about
maybe a boycott
but we didn't have a lot of credence to
that so we kind of just went about our
day
preparing for the game as normal once we
got to the venue in arena
you know the orlando magic were out
warming up their pre-game warm-up you
know with coaches kind of shooting
and so were the milwaukee bucks some
players out there but as time began to
pass a little bit and
orlando magic went back to their locker
room uh to begin their preparations
their pre-game prep
last minute adjustments before they came
back out for their final warm-up for the
game
they came back out and we noticed that
the milwaukee bucks have yet to
enter onto the court and as the time
began to
you know um count down to
zero on the game clock uh no milwaukee
bucks came to the court
and at that point we got word that there
had been a players meeting and that they
had decided
because of uh the shooting of jacob
blake and what was going on in kenosha
that they would uh boycott the
basketball game
and then you're trying to process this
what's orlando do because i thought they
were kind of caught
off guard here uh it felt like i don't
know when the bucks voted on this jim
but it felt like i don't know if it was
a rush to vote or last minute but it
felt like
they should have given at least orlando
a heads up there because orlando
they're still on the floor and i'm going
what is going on here
yeah yeah i agree to some to some point
and i want to back up a little bit i do
think a couple players from the box
i have had a private meeting the night
before and talked about this okay
now when they brought it to their
teammates i'm really not for sure
but uh it was brought in time in order
to to uh
put a game plan in place in regards to
the orlando magic sometimes with a plan
like this
if it's going to be enacted the right
way if it's the milwaukee bucks i think
they felt it was better
in their best interest to wait until
they had everything in place
because again they put out calls through
the ownership to the attorney general's
office in wisconsin
also the district attorney's office in
kenosha
to talk about the case itself so they
had a plan in place
it worked the orlando magic jumped on
board and hence
the other teams later that day also
decided that
the boycott was necessary if you were
still in the nba
what would you want to hear now as you
move forward
that would keep you in the bubble well
you know dan i've been asked that a lot
and that's a trick question because i
say that because as a
man that's now 49 about to be 50 my
thought process
is a lot different how i would think at
24 25 26 years old without having the
education
and the reading and the knowledge that i
have now is a lot different but i would
want to see it planned together
in regards to pushing the narrative of
social justice
also um you know racial inequalities
um but for the players itself what what
what they've been saying
all along pre-bubble post bubble during
the bubble
is that we need to take more leadership
our owners
need to take more responsibility within
our communities
because if we don't do it if we don't
have a voice then we're asking
others who don't have who have been
marginalized who don't have the platform
to affect change we more than anybody
else have
the opportunity to do that not just we
as the players
but from an ownership because you have a
vested interest not only in the nba
more importantly you have a vested
interest in the communities in which you
are located what does the commissioner
need to do today
i think jim had a freeze up with his
connection here
we'll see if we can reconnect with him
yeah because i was wondering if the
commissioner goes to the board of
governors i don't even know who's on the
board of governors with the nba we
discussed this before the show and i
looked up the board of governors and
there's
no clear list there's a board of
governors of the uh
basketball hall of fame but i don't know
if those are the same people who are the
board of governors of the nba yes
i read that it's the commissioner the
owners and their representatives so i
don't know who the representatives means
but it's
the owners are part of the board of
governments what i just read on that
side
so it's an owner's meeting i think so
yeah pretty much
yeah i think there are other people in
the room too yeah because i don't know
when the commissioner gets together with
them
like what do the owners want from the
commissioner what's the commissioner one
from the owners
and then you're gonna have a players
only meeting from what i'm told
at what point do you do that because if
you have a basketball game at four
o'clock this afternoon
you're going to have to get these guys
you know shoot arounds uh whatever it
might be you got to go into your normal
protocol
your routine uh to be able to do this is
uh
jim back with this time hey uh jim sorry
about that we uh we lost you there for a
moment
uh what do you want to hear from the
commissioner today or what do you think
he should say today
well i think he's what i think he's
going to say is he supports the players
because
with throughout the um
time of putting in place the bubble it's
always been about the
mbpa and the nba working together
and you see and i think it's witnessed
by the amount of content
that was produced and put together to
support these narratives
okay so i don't see it going any other
way
or going left in regards to what the
commissioner will say now what comes out
of the board a governor
governor's meeting is very important in
regards to what is next on the agenda
collectively as a group with the players
and the owners and the nba
so i wouldn't expect adam silver to sway
away from
the narrative that the players are
continuing to
pursue if a player asks you if he should
play what would you say
i say do what's in your heart because
that's what's important
what jim jackson would do uh is a lot
different but i will say this too that
if you want to if you really want to
affect change and then you've been
around enough to know this
change is uncomfortable uncomfortable
maybe to yourself and to a lot of other
people
and if you're not willing to deal with
that uncomfortableness
then you're not going to be able to
fully you're not going to be able to
fully give the effort and achieve the
goals that you want because you can't
have it halfway
you can't say i want social change but i
only want to give a little bit of your
time
and sacrifice in order for it to happen
if you're going to be the beacon of
light
you got to go all in if you're not all
in allow somebody else to do it
that can push the agenda in the
narrative in a way where now
we really do affect social change i
couldn't help but think of kyrie irving
last night jim
believe it or not because it was a
couple of weeks ago kyrie said what he
said and people
came down hard on him like we if we
really are all in it
uh for social activism and justice we
should not be playing basketball games
because it'll take away
from the narrative here and i'm
paraphrasing here and
people came down hard on him saying oh
you're not even healthy enough to be
playing in the bubble
you know if you were healthy would you
be saying this and
kyrie what he said uh i think is ringing
true today in a lot of
people's ears you know it is too and
everybody is entitled to their own
opinion i do believe that
with the restart of the nba
the platform was wide open for a lot
more
conversation that i don't know
really would have taken place because
the platform in regards to the media was
there social media
the games on tv the players had outlets
each and every day to kind of push
uh the message that they were trying to
relay uh throughout the country
and the voices so heard from the nba
unlike maybe football from an
international perspective so
kyrie had did have a point in regards to
taking away from
the meat of the movement but at the same
time i do believe that
being in the bubble while i've been here
has a couple things happen dan
one again has been broadcast nationally
internationally
the advertisements the companies that
have gotten
involved the groups that have supported
um you know
um minority businesses and opportunities
have happened but also the players
have had a chance to spend time with
each other
you know for hours for days that they
wouldn't
normally wouldn't have so i get a chance
to talk to some guys on another team
and we can trade notes we can come
together and talk about what's next
post this nba season and that allowed
these players now to come together and
kind of make the decision that we're
seeing
or we we will see later today i think
spread apart
you don't the confluence of things that
have come together you don't you still
don't kind of get that
so i do think that it's had value being
in the bubble
as we see today he's jim jackson former
nba player
now an analyst on nba on tnt how much
pressure do you think is on lebron right
now
it's a lot of pressure um because he's
the face of the league he's the face of
social change when it
speaks upon the nba but
certain people are built to handle it
and is you know is it always
the is it always easy no
if you look at our leaders throughout
history it's
never easy when you're put in a
situation where
everyone is expecting you to lead the
way
because you're not perfect you're human
the
insights that you may have based upon
your upbringing
may not equate or agree with other
people you're going to get people that
are going to be negative towards you
but if you're doing things for the right
reason okay and your heart is in the
right place and it's not about you
then you can carry that burden okay and
lebron has done an outstanding job
is it sometimes too much yeah but you
know what
it's certain people throughout history
that have been able to be placed in that
situation
and be able to handle the moment i'm
waiting to see and i'm anticipating that
lebron james will be able to step
up and handle this moment just as he's
done any other one
do you think it's a real possibility
that the season is canceled
i do i do and for a bigger reason too
dan
it's it's the social justice issue and
the racial discrimination is
is something that is an interesting
concept because we're asking people
to say look at me as a person not as a
second-class citizen
you know throughout our history we've
had many amendments
laws i don't care if it's a civil rights
act i don't care if it's fair housing
discrimination
13 14 14 15th amendment we've had laws
to say
discrimination voter suppression uh
racial inequality is wrong but
laws are pin to paper unless you're
able to change someone's mindset or
their mindset is able to change on how
you view
the person that looks a little bit
different than you and you don't treat
them like a second-class citizen
all of these things that we're trying to
accomplish
it doesn't matter because the people in
power the people that
control the pen still see you
as a second-class citizen and until that
changes
that's a reason why it's been
perpetuated
for 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 100 years
of having the same conversation
see me as your equal i don't want to be
better than you
i'm not asking for anything more than
you i'm just asking for the same
opportunities that you are afforded as
an american
that's it and until you change that
mindset dan and that
and it starts with education when kids
are young on how they
view themselves and other minority
groups
because when you're taught when you're
young that you're superior
to african americans native americans
latino american
chinese-american you grow up that way
and conversely dad
as these minority groups are told that
they're inferior
they grow up with an inferior complex
and always feel that they're
marginalized
it's well said i have a theory that when
muhammad ali passed away in the summer
of 2016
i think it opened a whole new
generation's eyes to what ali
stood for and who he really was and the
reaction to his death
at the espys that year he had lebron and
d wade and chris paul and carmelo and
they got up there and they
that's when i think this kind of started
with certainly the nba players
and just what ali went through
a lot of people probably didn't
understand um
and then all of course later in his life
he's beloved
you know he's lighting the the flame at
the olympics in atlanta
um and but i do think that something was
hatched
that day or soon after when people
started
seeing the clips of ali and who he
really was and what he stood for
because you have to be willing to give
up something
and he did kaepernick gave up something
uh john carlos and tommy smith gave up
something
but others have to give up something as
well it can't just be on
just these players and i think that's
the important part as we move forward
dan i'm glad you brought up muhammad ali
muhammad ali who is my favorite athlete
of all time and keep in mind
back when he changed his name to cassius
clay to muhammad ali
and he converted over to the muslim
religion
during that time when he was outspoken
about the vietnam war
about racial inequities and inequalities
even in the black community he was
shunned because a lot of black people
thought that he was hurting the civil
rights movement
he was popular but he was unpopular in a
lot of circles
because he was rocking the boat so to
speak
it was a black man at the time in the
60s
that spoke against the powers that be
so the muhammad ali that a lot of people
to your point saw
later in life that beloved one of the
most beloved athletes of all time
it wasn't like that he had to go through
that struggle
he had to go through that pain i'm sure
there were times in his lives
where he thought to himself is it all
worth it
because i'm not only endangering myself
but i'm endangering my family
but he stayed with it again the
sacrifice for him
was worth the cost down the line and
right now
with these young athletes because of
social media the times have changed
and i think young people in general they
see
a different side of the world and people
and say to themselves especially
athletes now in basketball
we have an opportunity to do something
now
what that opportunity will move forward
to
we have to push the narrative but we
also have to be willing like you said to
give up something
what is that our time our money
um you know to to be able to
meet with our ownership and demand that
within these 30 cities where our nba
teams are located
you have a better presence in regards to
voter suppression
um racial injustices uh the
incarceration
justice you know those things are
pushing the narrative and
if you don't do that then we're going to
put the ball down and walk away
until these demands are met
good to talk to you jim i appreciate
your time i know you had a long day
yesterday and you're certainly starting
out with a long day today but uh thank
you for your thoughts
anytime thanks dan that's jim jackson
nba on tnt analyst